heureux qui comme les enfants de l'école
doc sinon on fait un beau voyage le plus
beau voyage de leur vie pour certains
dont les yeux pétillent encore de
bonheur on se remémorant l'épopée de
carros ils sont aujourd'hui ici à la
bibliothèque départementale pour graver
dans le marbre les souvenirs des moments
heureux
carnet de voyage au carnet d'un voyage
sur les traces d'un enfant du pays
roland garros à bord de son avion
le morane saulnier là je crois qu'il
avril
traverser la mer méditerranée c'est le
fable c'est le foie malmö prcg un grand
voyage qui les amenait de la réunion à
paris en passant par monaco fréjus et
enfin bizerte
c'est ce qui sera inscrit dans leur
carnet impressions de voyage de découper
coller donne comme les voyages même
lajunie des photos des photos qu'il a
prises
un travail collectif où chacun présente
une oeuvre d'inspiration personnelle
c'est avec l'aide de gabrielle manglou
artiste plasticienne que les enfants de
guerre aux fabriques leur précieux car
des intérêts plutôt ici c'est que chacun
fasse ce qu'amène manière de manière
individuelle qui va y avoir des
consignes évidemment pour le groupe mais
on essaye jessel en tout cas que chacun
valorise ses talents intérieur son
organisation sa logique propre ça sert
un peu à l'instar de son côté le
professeur rappelle les lieux ici nous
étions au musée de l'espace là à fréjus
et puis il y a eu paris les champs
elysées disney
l'espace des voyages donc il fait suite
au violent bio voyage et dans le cas de
la traversée de roland-garros donc à
partir de souvenirs qu'ils ont collecté
au cours du voyage appartient aux idées
des illustrations fait apporter des
émotions et aussi bien entendu de les
écrits de rédaction au quotidien les
voyages forment la jeunesse
et ceux là ont pris goût à l'avion celui
de guerre us mais aussi celui qui les a
menés à l'autre bout du monde
bonne droite à l'elysée c'est déjà la
tunisie vendredi
un carnet de voyage pour garder à jamais
le souvenir de cette traversée vers
tunis et bizerte les enfants heureux
d'avoir vu la franche paris le palais de
l'elysée il ne souhaite désormais qu'une
chose fabriqués au plus vite d'autres
souvenirs et d'autres carnet de voyage